[Music]
for the alliance
[Applause]
[Music]
for azeroth
hi everyone i'm john height general
manager for warcraft and with me today
are my friends ian has acostas who is
the game director for world of warcraft
and holly longdale who leads up the
production team for wow classic
i really appreciate you tuning in i know
we're really excited to be able to give
you updates on what's happening in world
of warcraft but first i want to thank
our community for all the feedback
you've given us this year and especially
our community council you've helped
shape and influence the updates that
we've done recently and what you're
going to see in the upcoming year i mean
really for shadowlands in particular the
story of the last nine months or so of
this expansion is all about the
community and it's shaped by what we've
been hearing from them
and us realizing as a team that we just
collectively needed to do a better job
of making sure the community felt heard
and so that led us to the changes we
made in 915
but also really re-examining some of the
assumptions and foundations of world of
warcraft about things like character
investment and mains versus alts or how
catch-up should work or the appropriate
role of friction in our systems
and i think 915 represented a step in
the direction of letting players have
more freedom to play world of warcraft
the way they want to play it
and we really built our eternities and
content update from the ground up around
those principles what are some of the
things that the community said that
influenced your decisions for eternities
in things like the method and pacing of
acquisition of the covenant legendary
item tons of tuning and i think every
step of the way
um we were listening to make sure that
we were carrying forward those lessons
learned in the course of 915
into eternity's end and beyond so
wow classic was really came about
because of the community yeah they
continue to help guide and support us as
classic evolves world of warcraft has
always been about the world and the
players that inhabit it
and we are in a lot of ways curators and
caretakers of that journey and of that
experience and so once this classic
community formed and grew
we had to listen to them it's this tide
of listening to the community and paying
attention to what is a good experience
for our players now
and where we really saw a sea change in
this idea is with our season of mastery
realm which is a season of fresh start
classic and initially we were talking
about it like it was going to be like a
fresh start let's try this experiment in
a season it'll be about a year long and
then when the community found out about
it we started seeing this upswell yeah
the team just took that idea and ran
with it and turned you know what started
out as a small community project
into this soul of iron system that
became a centerpiece of season of
mastery in a whole new
opt-in hardcore mode that we've seen
communities built around
lots of you know
thrilling victory and painful defeat
five hours i mean
yeah and it continues like burning
crusade classic we wanted to balance the
paladin seals between horde and alliance
so we made an addition there we wouldn't
have gotten there without the
community's input
so
influence the community you've got
another update and pretty significant
controversial change for this yeah cross
faction play uh coming coming in nine
two five uh which is on a public test
rom now uh a big centerpiece faction
you're breaking with a 17-year tradition
yeah it's something it was not an easily
made decision by any means you know and
i think this is another one of those
areas where really
we try to take to heart community
feedback and requests and ask ourselves
as a team whether there's a way
to accommodate such an earnestly held
desire
and still feel like we're being true to
the to the roots of the game i think
players desire to play with their
friends who might prefer a different
faction or to play with the faction that
they more closely identify with even
though their ray group is elsewhere it's
really important for me i play a lot of
alts and i love absorbing the story for
each race and
having that ability to play with all of
my friends across factions is fantastic
at the end of the day
the battle cry is for the horde it's not
against the alliance it's not death to
the alliance it's about pride in one's
faction and i think there's a way to
preserve that and even strengthen that
while giving players the ability to make
the same choice we've seen the greatest
heroes make time and time again i can't
wait to do this i'm seeing a lot of my
friends that i never knew had a max
level character in the other faction
suddenly come out of the woodwork and
then you know with these these
cross-faction groups many of them are
going to be diving into something new
that we're doing to kind of cap off
shadowlands a season four
kind of a remix a little bit a bit of a
greatest hits revisiting our all of our
raid zones across the expansion bringing
in some
familiar older favorites into the mythic
plus rotation and you know we recognize
this is kind of a closing chapter a
little bit of a send-off to shadowlands
as everyone gets ready for what happens
next what will come next want to give
you know a fun new challenge for
everyone to sink their teeth into really
cool stuff for for modern wow players
i'm super excited about the gear
upgrades you're going to give me and the
chance to go back and play some of those
those awesome raids there's a lot to
explore very exciting for our next
adventure in world of warcraft
we're going to go back to azeroth
we're going to a space with high fantasy
i mean our fans have asked for this for
a long time this has been kind of the
foundation of much of the lore of wow
so without further ado let's watch the
cinematic
[Music]
the world has been sundered
it cries out in pain
we must go to its aid
we entrust our ancestral home to you
the watchers
[Music]
even from our own eyes
you will feel our return
in the waking of the land
then
you must light the beacon of tear hold
let the path home be lost to us
forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world is healing
but her fate is yet uncertain
together
we shall be azeroth's protectors once
again
here
the new age of dragons shall begin
[Music]
[Music]
dragons dragons this is so cool no one's
not coming no inside coming carefully
kept secret but seriously i mean
what did we just see there
the awakening of the dragon isles the
return of dragons the dawn of a new age
right we've seen wrathion searching for
his father's legacy searching for the
dragon isles there's a reason why he
hasn't been able to find them until now
the beacon going off is that summoning
the dragons it is removing the
concealment that had hidden the dragon
isles from the world but also beckoning
the dragons back urgently
in a time of need i assume
pretty good variety of locales within
the dragon isles yes the dragon isles as
kind of standard for wow expansion
consist of five zones four standard
leveling zones and a new starter zone
that we'll get to in a second can you
talk a little bit about how the team
found ways to thread the dragon aspects
throughout the environments the the
dragon isles are a place that is lush
and primal bursting with elemental
energy as azeroth herself reawakens
those primal forces are expressed
throughout the environment whether it's
magma activity volcanic activity whether
it's the icy wastes of the azure spam
and each one of those has a connection
to a dragon flight that we've seen
before and it's going to be an amazing
place for players to arrive at and
explore all right you know i'm going to
ask yes okay so
can i be a dragon
let's start getting into some features
here and what dragonfly means for you as
well as just a place um so first off yes
we have an all-new playable race the
drak theater race yeah
this is a draconid draconic race but
dragons in warcraft have the ability to
take on a humanoid form
what classes can they be they have
unique abilities as literally a dragon
that doesn't quite fit any of our
existing classes and so what we're doing
is this is not just a new race but it's
also a new class you know adding a new
race to world of warcraft and not just
an allied race is something that we
don't do lightly
but telling this expansion the story so
focused around dragons felt like the
perfect time for it so if you were a
drac theater you will be the evoker
class drag there can only be evokers
evokers can only be drackfear and the
reason why only a dracula could be an
evoker is that an evoker is really
combining
the ability to call upon the magic of
the different aspects with the unique
physical gifts that a drachthir has the
ability to actually take flight and do
an enyxia style strafing deep breath
over the battlefield land on the other
side
knock everyone back with a wing buffet
and then unleash your magical abilities
yes please
yes please
the evoker has two specializations
they're a hybrid of either ranged dps or
healer and they wear male armor we
figured you know with the new hero
classes classes we've added over the
years we have enough melee we don't need
more of those
and also probably don't need any more
any more leather wearers the raid
leaders are going to love you for that
exactly this is definitely a hero class
and so that means that you know like the
death knights before them or demon
hunters they will be starting level 58
and then they're going to have a new
starter zone so they're going to have a
slightly different journey into the
dragon isles as opposed to the rest of
us that are sailing there from other
parts of azeroth
can you talk a little bit about the
customizations like what is going to be
able to identify my drag pair character
basically anything and everything you
know skin color hair color jewelry
tattoos other adornments you can make
this character the expression of your
identity in azeroth
new zone
new class yep erase well tell us about
some of the the system updates yeah
futures of course the new expansion
brings with it you know new systems new
features i think in recent expansions
one of the things we've tended to do is
really have these deep features that
were closely tied to a specific
expansion that would then get left
behind as we moved on
and we've heard loud and clear from
players that you know it's kind of a
bummer to start off every new expansion
by leaving a large part of your
character behind by leaving a large part
of your progression behind so this time
around what we're doing is really
pouring all of our energy into permanent
revamps overhauls and improvements to
world of warcraft's core systems things
like our progression systems in this
case our talent system is something that
we want to completely revamp we want to
take a look at our ui we want to take a
look at professions so with the talent
revamp and the arrival of classic did
you learn anything about how our talents
work i think seeing a new generation of
players play with those talents and work
through those talent trees really
underscored some of the things that
frankly we lost when we shifted to the
mists of pandaria style talents and
beyond a big piece of that was some just
the granularity the feeling of getting a
level and spending a point to customize
your character to make yourself a bit
better in some specific way
but also you know that sense of
hybridity that you could have that's
something that we've largely lost and so
the new talent system avoids directly
pitting
player power throughput choices directly
against those sort of utility hybrid
choices because we know that there's
always a right outcome there and we also
understand that you know there's a lot
of strength in the flexibility of the
modern talent system to let players
customize their talents for a particular
encounter or for dungeons versus pvp and
we don't want to lose any of that
so john ui oh my god
yes i got this 30 inch monitor trying to
keep track of where i am on the map all
my buffs and oh over here what's going
on in chat it has literally made my eyes
go like this so
you're not alone in that we've made a
lot of incremental changes and additions
over the years but really this is a
revamp this is an overhaul and so we're
excited to really modernize the look and
feel while staying true to the origins
of world of warcraft you know at the
same time we're not looking to take away
the sort of power user customization
there add-ons are still there if you
want them but we want a much better
default out of the box experience for
all players new and old alike and can i
reduce elements remove elements if i
want to explore the world and see the
beauty of azeroth when it comes to
specific elements as much as possible we
want to let players choose what to show
and what to hide so that they can
control it themselves you mentioned
professions
i have a critical question about this
go on
can i wear a chef's hat yeah i knew it
[Laughter]
our approach to professions in dragonfly
is really all about delivering on
fantasy and identity as a crafter and so
if you want to be a serious blacksmith
if you want to be a great leather worker
we want to deliver the ability to invest
time and energy into that become a
master crafter be able to make items
that are in demand interact with the
community one of the big pieces that we
want to do to support that is a new work
order system to have a bit more
convenience than just spamming trade
chat all day but if you or someone
you're not yourself a blacksmith but you
have a bunch of mats and you want them
forged into a great sword
you can put that work order up list your
mats offer a commission and a skilled
blacksmith can come along and make you
the weapon of your dreams
i think we left out one thing though
be a drag there go to dragon isles can i
have a dragon what's the fantasy of
dragons if not soaring over the lands
and so we're really excited to introduce
a feature that we're calling dragon
riding it's dynamic with you know
everything from momentum to dive bombs
the ability to you know just sort of
build that speed up and feel the world
rushing past you in a way that should be
much more exciting than traditional
flight that we've had made available in
the past but that's also available
for players through a customizable
dragon mount right from the start so
this is a skill you learn over time
right to become an awesome dragon rider
yes you'll be able to sort of upgrade
aspects of your flight but you will have
this new form of flight from the start
and the dragon companion that you have
is of course very thoroughly
customizable which is a new a new thing
for us for mounts this is not just a
generic dragon that everyone has but a
drake that is yours you know what what
do you want its scales to look like
horns the shape of its head other
attachments armor pieces and more take
your pick this is so cool
so yeah so the dragonflight expansion is
going to see players leveling to 70
going to the all-new continent of the
dragon isles which consists of five
zones four standard leveling zones and a
new starter zone for our drakthier class
as well as a range of systems revamps
such as a new talent system an overhaul
an update to our ui and an entirely
fresh look at professions with more
depth than ever before
also getting around the dragon isles is
going to come in the form of dragon
riding which lets you customize and
upgrade your own mount so that you can
fly in a sense from the start and of
course as with any new expansion we have
a new set of dungeons a raid and much
more to come we also have an alpha that
will be starting up in in in the future
check out our website for more
information and keep an eye out for
those opt-in sign ups if you want to
help us test out dragonflight and give
us even more feedback to make it better
we do have a deep dive that follows this
so please stay around
classic players we haven't forgotten
about you you could probably guess where
we're gonna go next one of the all-time
favorite expansions for world of
warcraft let's watch the cinematic
we had forgotten
did you think
my son
the day you were born
the very forests of lordaeron whispered
the name
arthas
when my days have come to an end
you
shall be
king
[Music]
it's just incredible isn't it every time
i see the cinematic i get chills no pun
intended i do i get chills as you saw
wrath of the lich king classic is coming
this year it brings back so many
memories when you see that cinematic
what do you remember from wrath of the
lich king anytime you wanted to talk
about undead frozen dragons how can you
not go back to syndragosa as the source
that was the first expansion i played
with my youngest son so i can remember
on that platform black goo and you know
chunks of ice falling off and and having
to repeat that battle with the lich king
but when we finally downed him it was
such an incredible moment he jumped up
out of his room and i jumped up out of
my office
[Laughter]
so it's a very lasting tale for me
so as you know with this expansion you
will in pre-patch be able to play the
death knight they will start at level
55. you don't have to have a high level
character to make a death knight so
everyone will be able to make one we're
excited to give players some time before
wrath officially launches to get geared
up and ready to jump in to northrend
with everybody else and there are so
many zones and areas to explore in
northrend and i want us to talk about
some of our favorites so for me grizzly
hills has a very special place in my
heart the music was some of the best
i've experienced in world of warcraft i
still only make my way all the way up to
storm peaks to try and find the time
lost proto-drake and have yet to get it
i've got to say dragon blight the wide
open nature of the zone warmers temple
in the center of it it's an
unforgettable expansion as both a
developer and a player and kind of
making that transition from one to the
other now let's talk about some changes
so one thing we looked at is dungeon
finder and it feels like how we envision
classic dungeon finder is not a good fit
for our community that was kind of the
first step that may have eroded some of
that social fabric now as people gone
through the experience of going back to
vanilla rebuilding those groups relying
on each other
not wanting necessarily a random
participant just to show up and then
leave yep yeah that makes total sense
but today you can do that in shadowlands
you'll be able to do that in dragonfly
it's a self-selected group of people who
specifically want that different
experience let's make sure that's what
we continue to give them that leads
right into
arena teams in burning crusade classic
so we'd listen to the community and we'd
remove that because individual rating is
preferable a better experience for them
than arena teams also with wrath of the
lich king barbershop which allows you to
customize your character we're going to
be adding a few more options that were
not existing when wrath launched but
also there's another side of this where
we are not going to charge a real money
fee it was a paid character
customization fee right yeah it seems
the right thing to do that that just be
available in game for gold and we add
more options to it right it's sort of
like spell batching in a sense there's a
lot of technical advancements and it's
not about the philosophy of what makes
classic classic what brings people
together it's just what's the better
experience
and let's not artificially restrict
something that we can provide a better
version of just for the sake of
nostalgia and this is we're happy to say
this is one of those cases so
wrath the level caps being increased at
level 80 so we'll be introducing a level
70 boost so that players who want to get
in with their friends or just explore
northrend right away we'll be able to do
that you can't apply it to a death
knight but you will be able to use it
otherwise and of course we have
inscription a whole new profession so
we're really excited about that yeah and
as we continue this road to wrath we're
going to be looking to getting a lot
more feedback on beta and we'll make
changes as we need to
such an exciting time to be playing
world of warcraft we have the return of
the wrath of lich king for classic fans
and taking us somewhere new with
dragonfly we're so excited to be able to
bring these adventures to you don't
forget there's a deep dive on
dragonflight where you're going to get a
lot more information thank you so much
for spending this time with us and we'll
see you in azeroth and we'll see you in
northrend
and in the dragon isles
hi there welcome to the dragonflight
deep dive i'm steve denuzer and i'm
taryn gregory starting it off here we're
going to talk about the setting and the
story of dragonflight we've got this
great expansion uh exciting pre-render
trailer that everyone just watched so
let's talk about the setting for
dragonflight the dragon isles dragon
isles have been
known for a long time in warcraft
history as a mysterious place where the
dragons came from long ago but we never
knew much more than that we're going to
this place that is kind of the brood
lands of all the dragonflights the place
where they nested where they built their
civilization the dragon isles was the
center of the dragon's kingdom when the
world was young and the mortal races
were just starting to form kingdoms of
their own but when the legion invaded
for that war of the ancients that
sundering that resulted from the the
explosion of the well of eternity
literal world literal sundering of the
continents of azeroth and because of the
breaking of the world that magic kind of
drained away and the land went dormant
so they had to leave the dragon isles
behind and as we saw in the pre-render
they left behind some titan watchers to
look over the land and when
someday they hoped that elemental energy
would resurge once again and draw the
dragons home re-establish their kingdom
and that's when the message goes out to
the flights and they feel it in their
bones now it's the time for the sky to
light up with the colors of the aspects
once again
and for alex strazza and the others to
come home but the land has changed a lot
in all these thousands of years they've
been away and some very old threats have
awakened as well we're looking into the
culture of dragons as they exist in
warcraft dragons as we know them today
were very different in the early past
the early history of azeroth they were
much more primitive much more savage
what we now know as proto-dragons and
then some of the dragons were empowered
to become the aspects the green flight
red flight blue flight bronze flight
black flight each with unique powers
each with the ability to protect the
world in different ways these pillars of
draconic power appointed to defend
azeroth from threats within and without
dragons used that power both for good in
the case of most of the aspects but also
for nefarious reasons in the case of the
black dragonflights led by nilfarian who
would become deathwing and what we will
find in dragonfly is that some of these
ancient divisions run deep and so it
begs the question where do we go from
here if this is an opportunity to
reclaim their legacy to be the
protectors as the cinematic mentioned
that they once were to do that they're
going to need the help of our heroes our
players to come to the dragon isles with
them and face some of these reawakening
challenges because it's not just that
this land is peacefully waiting for the
dragons to return and reclaim it there's
those old enemies that have awakened as
well yeah one of those being a race of
kind of
elemental half giants the jared the
dragon isles isn't just populated by
dragons or just by the jared and there's
also many other occupants here in the
dragonells i've been here either just
recently or for a while including a fan
favorite coming back the tuskar that's
going to be awesome we've got other
cultures there as well in the dragon
isles we're going to find out about a
civilization of centaurs that predates
the ones that arose on calum dormant
later and some of our favorite
characters that we've seen over the last
few expansions such as wrathion and
whether he's ready to step up into a
leadership role or if there are other
alternatives out there that would be
better suited to the job of being the
aspect of the black dragonfly
i think one thing the
players are going to be really excited
about this expansion is the new playable
race the drak fear that's right and this
is something that neltharion before he
was deathwing before he went full crazy
world dragon that he put into motion
niltharian saw those primalists that
were kind of breaking away from the
aspects and what they wanted and so in
those first experiments he took the
essence of dragons their strength their
nobility their wisdom and he combined it
with that scrappiness that that
adaptability that the mortal races had
and he wanted to use that to create
the ideal soldier in his mind the drak
there
exploration is really one of the key
themes of this expansion you're we're
going to be going to this ancient place
that the dragons left behind long ago so
we've made these huge zones with all
kinds of places to delve into and find
little treasures and little secrets
tucked away it's gonna be a lot of fun
for players to be exploring these
landscapes and there's so much
architectural history in how clearly
aspirational was the kingdom of the
dragons and how
it lost so much and the themes of trying
to return to that to try to find your
legacy
to try to figure out who you were before
everything went awry
but there's questions you know thematic
questions of
what does it mean to be true to your
legacy are we going to repeat the
mistakes of the past the dragons have
had to learn those lessons just like the
mortal kingdoms have had to and i think
that's one of the reasons why the
dragons see this now is the time that
they have to return and they have to
step up once again as protectors of
azeroth we're helping the dragons
because the dragons have helped us in
the past too so by using the explorers
league and the reliquary together that
allows us to delve into some of that
history and when i look you know upon
the dragon isles and all of its visual
splendor i get so excited for the
prospect of a truly azerothian adventure
alongside calicos along with wrathion
ebenhorn
with isera's daughter marithra as each
one of them is trying to find their own
flights
i am taken
by the exploration and the potential for
adventure and just new horizons within
this world there's going to be old
stories from that time past that history
that only the dragons knew for the
longest time we're going to be able to
explore that it really feels like just a
breath of fresh air so now we're going
to turn things over to some of our
colleagues who will take you on that
deep dive into the locations and the
features of dragonflight
hello i'm stephanie i'm josh i'm jackie
and i'm gary and we're part of the teams
that are building the first two zones
they encounter in the dragon isles the
waking shore and the anaran plains
the very first zone in dragon flight
you're going to come to is the waking
shores
it's wild untamed land it's waking up
around you too and the elements are just
going crazy the art team again has
headed out of the park you'll see like a
lava mountain flowing in through the
beach giant proto dragon swooping down
gobbling up members of your expedition
we have such rife opportunities to show
elementals rising up because of the
crazy magic that's flying around
the one of the things i love is just how
you get to the dragon isles right so
you're gonna get on your boat and storm
window orgrimmar and the first thing you
do is sail between like the dragon ruin
architectures the boats come right
alongside each other you can jump from
one boat to the other and just start
causing havoc on the other faction's
boat for those who love pvp this is a
great opportunity for war mode it's
free-for-all out there it's gonna be
great
but it's okay there's an innkeeper on
the beach so that if you're in that
situation you don't want to be in war
mode anymore you can just hop out right
there the reliquary and the explorers
league are working together the horton
alliance are sending an expedition
together it's not the military it's not
the soldiers this is the scientists the
settlers exploring this new land so it's
a lot more optimistic tone one of my
favorite things about the waking shores
is the red dragon flight led by queen
alextraza the lifebinder they have the
mandate of nurturing and protecting all
life which means quartum alliance
gorloks
trolls everybody so they take that duty
seriously when the horde and the lions
come to the waking shores they want to
be there to help guide the people
through the new land and welcome them
but they're not the only one in the
waking shores
we have the ancestral home of the black
dragon flight there too which has fallen
on tough times since deathwing's descent
and so wrathion's coming over to the
isles with us and he's gonna try and
come to terms with the state of the
dragon flight which is a few loyal
draconids and dragon spawn trying to
hold their ground what can the future of
the dragonflight be if it's just
wrathion
because it's not just the dragons that
are coming back to the dragon isles but
also their longtime rival the jardin i
love the jardin so much they're half
giants that wield the power of magma and
when the waking shores and the dragonais
went to slumber they also slumbered
they're back now and they are ready to
raise chaos yeah they're massive they're
riding giant lava mammoths parading
around just stomping on your face and
they were the enemies of the dragonfly
for so long they fought against the red
dragon flight hunted dragons down and
they're really taking this opportunity
to rise up as the red dragonflight have
the mandate of nurturing life they don't
want to just stomp out the jardin
completely but they want to make sure
that they don't have the power to affect
those around them negatively to make
sure they don't go on a rampage and
destroy the ecosystem that has been
created here and so those are awesome
things in the waking shore but steph
there really is only one right answer
for the best thing in waking shores
right what this is true
ducks
they finally have those webbed feet
hooligans in our game we crack the
technology
figure it out they can fly you should be
proud thank you
it's gonna be awesome the unarmed planes
come right after the waking shores
it's so breathtaking at first glance the
onaron planes are big wide open planes
and the player is going to be
constricted a little bit and then you
see this big contrast of his own we
don't always get that opportunity that
cinematic moment where the player can
have a framed view when they see this
area come out and you got that postcard
shot of the planes
and then you see this giant fire proto
dragon breathing fire and a herd of
centaur like harpooned down the
proto-dragon crash into the ground and
the first thing you get to do is go help
them kill the frodo dragon like how cool
is that who is onara onara is the wild
god of the wind and she's appeared
before as like this big spirit eagle
she's the one who guided the centaur to
the dragon isles many many years ago she
blessed them took their caravan across
and then showed them the planes
how fun at the beginning of this
expansion was exploring the culture of
the centaur the centaur are these mighty
awesome hunters that back when they
first came to the dragon isles they
fought the green dragons all day long
eventually they realized that we're
strong you're a strong maybe we should
stop decimating each other's people um
we'll make peace we'll make an agreement
you guys hang out in the groves and the
centaur will hang out in the plains but
now the dragons have been gone for 10
000 years and the centaur have come so
far since then
and they've been here and they've been
existing and developing their culture
they all came over as one clan led by
the mighty maruk and tira and they
founded a new life here
so if you want to get across you have to
follow their rules and their traditions
you have to earn their trust you were
the first outsiders to come in
generations upon generations the centaur
might rule the open plains but the green
dragons make their home in the groves
and those groves are absolutely gorgeous
and how great a job it is that we have
where i can take all of this beautiful
artwork and build these beautiful
fantasy groves high fantasy
we want to do lots of things with an
open plane and we want to be creative
with that but we're restraining ourself
by letting the zone sing letting the
horizon tell the story we certainly
couldn't have done that in the vanilla
wow no definitely not the zones are so
big and you can see so far especially in
o'naran plains so we talk to the
engineers and we actually increase that
distance
it spurs you on to want to adventure and
look through the zone and explore
everything the interesting thing for me
is we have all these conflicts with the
dragon flights there's missing dragons
there's battles there's so much crazy
stuff happening but that's not really
all we're doing there's so much extra
fun activities for people to do and the
greatest thing is that you need to
figure out exactly what's going on and
help solve all the problems that are
just sprouting up everywhere we're just
really excited to tell a story that's
grounded in azeroth and exploration
there's so much more to talk about but
now we're gonna have some folks talking
about the next two zones that players
are gonna experience in the dragon isles
[Music]
hello everyone my name is kate i'm
christy i'm kate i'm sean we're going to
talk today about valdrazza's in the
azure span
so azure span is going to be the third
zone that players adventure through and
it's one of our biggest zones that we've
done in the dragonfly maybe even to date
we knew it was going to be like the
largest visual elevation change and it
really started with this great concept
art when we first were taking a look at
the design we kept coming back to one of
our favorite wrath zones which was
grizzly hills and we really wanted to
take that but wowify it more and i don't
know if you've ever been up to the bay
area but in the morning that coastal fog
comes in and dips down into the redwoods
and that sun shines through that's
really what we wanted to encapsulate
with this forest and not only we have
redwoods we've got all different types
of trees eventually it'll break open
into this wide open tundra that's just
golden and red and you'll reach up to
another level of elevation where you get
to see the snow the majority of the zone
is covered in snow and ice we have giant
frozen waterfalls ice rivers as far as
the eye can see and sean i know in the
forest we can expect our first creatures
we have a small group that lives there
called the knolls these knolls are all
throughout the forest and azure span
they've made this their home some nulls
with strange magic that we're going to
find out what exactly that's about snow
knolls or as i call them the
snows up in the winter area and then
some regular knolls that are just going
to be around the forest area so then we
go into the big open tundra where we
meet our second group the tescar it's
going to be really neat to explore their
culture a lot more and those kids are
adorable i absolutely love the tuscar
honestly all my down times probably
makes me hanging up the tuscar
so it's been a little while since you've
seen them we remember the tuscarora from
wrath of the lich king they're also
getting a nice cool uprise for their
models
along with expanding their culture so
there are going to be male tuscar female
tuscar tuscar kids so we're going to
fight alongside them which includes help
from a certain group of dragons the blue
dragons we're going to follow the story
of kalagos our blue dragon buddy from
the kierman tour and he's going to be
adventuring into syndragosa's archives
it's a giant zone there's a lot of
surprises when we're done there we head
over to al drouse's al trousers it's
really incredible because you will be
going through some of the previous zones
and seeing a lot of ruins uh for the
dragon uh buildings but when you get to
thal drazis everything is perfectly
intact it's beautiful it's pristine it
is the seat of power for all five dragon
flights and home of the dragons
it feels that way with the huge vertical
mountains we've got these great cave
systems where you may end up finding
little dragon hordes my favorite
dragonflight right now is the bronze
they've got a really cool area in the
aldrazos and their magic is time there's
so many cool story hooks that we could
dig into there there's so many cool
gameplay options and we have a little
bit of an adventure for players it's
gonna be a lot of fun i can't wait we
really wanted it to feel like their old
stomping grounds one of the really cool
features is going to be the main city
and player hub for this expansion
valdraken it is a culmination of all of
the dragon's efforts to put together
what a city would look like so we ended
up having a bunch of really fun small
vignettes where you see that the blue
dragon flight has hosting a public
library and the red and green dragon
flights both have their own separate
gardens we'll also have some convenience
services for players including an
auction house in the city which will be
really nice if you're looking for more
exotic wares
the thing that really sold me on with
aldrazos was the initial concept art we
got of tear hole oh yeah wow and this is
a ten thousand year old titan
technological marvel tier hold has these
awesome aqueducts that actually come out
from the structure all the way to the
city across the valley and in the
cinematic there's just this amazing shot
where you see alex straza swoop under
one of them and there's splashes of
water cresting across her wings so when
players are flying around themselves
they get to have their alexstrasza
moment what an incredible place and
filled with so much history
hold was built by tyr he was a titan
keeper back in the day who helped the
aspects fight galacron and when they
settled on the dragon isles he built
this facility and even though tyr's gone
the dragons have held him in reverence
but that was ten thousand years ago and
they've let the titans maintain the
place an incredible amount of history
has happened since then flights have
been nearly wiped out there have been
invasions betrayals aspects have died
and these are the kind of things that
leave marks on a society so now they're
all back here and they're all here
together as we were designing the zone
and the the city itself we're trying to
figure out you know how do we tell those
stories at the same time as making sure
that this is a really convenient place
for players to go and go shopping
because they tend to do
so much adventuring happening on the
dragon isles it's so cool
as a player you probably don't have your
own dragon wings you are going to learn
the art of dragon writing that's so
vertical and i'm just excited to like
dive off the tops of towers and swoop
under things it's actually one of the
things that we're about to learn about
next
hi i'm jake i'm andy i'm kali and i'm
graham and i'm really excited to talk to
you guys today about the drag theory
voker our new race and class coming in
dragon flight we're here to talk about
not only the evoker but also dragon
riding which is our exciting expression
into the exploration of the dragon isles
we knew with a dragon themed expansion
we wanted to let you play a dragon not a
big dragon alex draza size that'd be
tough to fit into raids i'm sorry jake i
know i know
but a draconic humanoid so the drak fear
created by neltharion and like our other
hero classes you get to choose if you
want to start on the horde or alliance
side on character creation so let's talk
a little bit about the evoker the class
they can be
what's unique about it is because the
the drak theater are created by an
aspect they have the ability to wield
the magic of all five dragon flights so
evokers can take advantage of red magic
and blue magic and bronze magic and to
show that we created a visual what we
call a prismatic effect this prismatic
effect is basically the coalescence of
all their energy as they channel it into
whatever spell that they're going to
cast you have a red magic spell called
pyre so when you shoot it out of your
mouth it twirls in the air with all five
of the dragonflight's magic as it turns
into the red spell before landing on
your enemies and exploding and hopefully
burning them i'll take that one
getting that vibe across that they use
all five was really important to us but
we did want to make sure that each
specialization focused on two because
casting five different colors gets a bit
messy so their damage dealer
specialization their first of two
devastation mostly focuses on red and
blue magic red being very fast and
explosive burning everything with pyre
whereas blue is more focused and
overwhelming you can shoot a beam of
energy out of your mouth to disintegrate
one single enemy in front of you there's
a healer spec called preservation the
healer spec is going to focus mostly on
your green and your bronze magic so your
green is going to be evocative of the
emerald dream your growth and your
nurturing spells and then you have your
bronze magic which is going to be more
tiny whiny so you get to heal a wound
faster so in addition to the visuals and
the animation which will make you feel
very powerful we really want the player
to have a physical connection to the
cast we have a new type of spell called
empower where when you actually hold
down the button on your keyboard it
charges up the spell the longer you
charge it up it might do more damage or
hit more targets depending on the spell
but it gives you this really physical
connection and control that's new for
world of warcraft and i think is feeling
really really good we have some great
animations thank you andy you're you're
you're just love it andy you feel
physical when you're casting your spells
you can actually fly around the
battlefield and cast while you're flying
raining fire and death from above it's
great
in addition to the gameplay though
another part of feeling draconic is
looking like a dragon well we talk about
dragons breathing fire but you know
what's actually fire what's actually
these customizations
but no they're really really they're
awesome cause you have both your
draconic form and your humanoid form and
the customization options for both of
them are amazing they're very good what
about color just tell me tell us about
the color color
you can do a lot of matching so your
visage form can have scales that are the
same color as your duck fear form but my
favorite super favorite part of
customization for the visage form
hair oh yeah
because i could actually do this in
games yeah the tech is here
we finally did it
as players make their way through each
of the areas of the dragon isles they'll
partner up with the dragonflights to
move through the air as they've never
done before you'll notice i did not say
flying because flight has a very
specific meaning for world of warcraft
and and we're talking about something
new called dragon riding
and as the players are honing their
dragon riding skills they're going to
get to see all new animations that go
along with the different look and feel
of the drakes we're aiming to shake up
movement with this new system providing
players with a deeper immersion with
forces like momentum and gravity we knew
that for dragonflight we're going to
have the opportunity to show players a
whole new set of dragon isle drakes
completely unique from all the other
things they've seen in world of warcraft
and so we wanted to come up with a
movement system
that would add that sense of physics
weight and gravity like you were
mentioning we knew it was going to take
a huge team effort not just animation
but it was going to take effects it was
going to take the engineering team who
we rely on heavily and that combined
with some new animations
really helps to lend that feeling of
physics as you move through the air in
ways that you haven't before and the
icing on the cake is going to be some
really cool effects that we've added on
top of all of that so for example when
you start hitting you know maximum
velocity you're going to see contrails
coming off the edges of the wings
and then as you do your rolls and
spirals you build up more and more speed
there's going to be some screen effects
on the display to indicate that you're
reaching maximum velocity which really
adds to the overall kind of immersion
and sense of reality
as players make their way through the
dragon isles they'll discover new
cosmetic options to fine-tune their
dragon isle drake's appearances
things like snoots horns tails elusive
dragon isle drake armor and more can i
have spikes definitely okay we want to
provide players with all new skills to
play with as those who can use their
momentum well can reach higher and
higher heights and bring on new more
difficult challenges we just have so
many new gorgeous options to choose from
and
i'm just so excited for all of them i'm
excited for the whole thing i mean it's
been a lot of fun to work on but i can't
wait to actually get in the game play it
with you guys i can't wait i can't wait
to fly around dragon isles it's gonna be
great next up you're going to hear about
the talent revamp and the ui changes
coming in dragonflight
[Music]
hello my name is brian i'm crash i'm jay
and i'm laura we are very excited to
share finally revamping the wow hud ui
and it is also time for a major revamp
to talents and specializations i have a
big question for the group how long do
you think it took for us to finally
revamp the wow hud my guess is like 15
years
close 18 years 18 18 years wow you know
technology has changed a lot since we
made the ui back in 2004. now you have
like bigger monitors and us we have
better dev tools to work with so it
makes sense to have the revamp right now
also if you look at the game today the
art evolved beautifully over the years
and if you look at the hud the hud looks
like it got frozen time so when we
approached this we wanted to create a
layout experience that players could
customize move things around adjust it
to fit their needs add-ons today they do
a lot for player customization the
downside is is that not everybody uses
them it's about time that everybody has
the opportunity to use them that they
become a part of the base ui yeah and we
are working very closely with our user
research team to make sure we are
hitting the goals their player needs it
allowed us to add new functionality to
improve accessibility in a lot of areas
and on top of that we are going to be
improving the art yeah so the art update
it's a big part of this project the ui
that we have today has a lot of charm
and personality and players have been
using that for 18 years so
with that in mind we want to respect the
place we really like the current ui but
do it more than take to it removing the
clutter and giving more visibility for
your gameplay so the new mini map it
looks bigger and the health bar is also
much bigger if you look at the action
bars and the bottom menus they have less
head frames and
it can really open up your gameplay so
you don't have a lot of ui in front of
you and of course we want to find iconic
pieces from the current hud but we want
to bring it back in a nice way so we for
sure updating the griffins they look so
nice now and the horde don't worry we
got you we're gonna have your version as
well so let's talk about the edit mode
we are putting a mode in that will let
players move
various hud elements around on the
screen so i'm able to move the minimap
say from the right corner all the way
over to the left corner if i want to
bring my action bars from the bottom and
kind of put them more in the center by
my character those are all things that
i'll be able to do absolutely and each
of those different components will have
various sets of options that you'll be
able to work with they'll be able to
save it edit it copy it name it also
it'll remember which spec you're in so
if you're someone who jumps around a lot
as you switch it will switch to whatever
hud layout you have for that spec this
is an ongoing project we're going to
keep working on it so
we really want to hear back from you a
project that we're all excited about
that we've been collaborating a lot on
is something that's pretty ui intensive
and that's the talent system it hadn't
changed in a long time like you said
before and we really started with how
can we have players have more choice
over what their character has as you
level up we give you a new spell or a
new ability something that kind of makes
you stronger but it's it's determined by
the designers we decide the order yeah
we started looking for a system that
would give players a much wider set of
options and after looking at all those
things what we really returned back to
was the idea of trees but it's actually
two trees we have a class stream that
offer different class utility and then
we have a spec tree that is focused on
performing your role whether that's
damage tank or healing can i just jump
in and say that i personally am super
excited about having trees come back
there's a big nostalgia hit for me as we
said we have these two trees because we
feel like picking a specialization is a
really important part of your world of
warcraft character now and so we want to
make sure that when you choose that it
kind of affects the tree in some way
yeah as soon as you open your talent
tree you'll see something new the class
side will have some abilities filled out
for free just kind of starting you off
in that spec you've chosen but then
you'll have your first point to spend in
the class tree which could be something
related to that spec or role or it could
be something from elsewhere in the class
there's a lot of things that we can do
here and part of that is encouraging
players to perhaps make combinations
that they've never really been able to
see in the game before this is an
opportunity to put a lot more art and
fantasy in the actual talent ui itself
you have seen that a lot through most
recent expansions but not the base ui we
want you to be able to tinker with it
you know we want you to be able to make
a lot of changes at a lot of times and
not necessarily
have to commit the power really is
coming back to the player
it's not something we want people to
feel locked into and so one of the
things that we'll be preserving is the
ability to change these talents uh it's
the same kind of frequency that you do
now yeah the old-school players when you
see trees this time just think yeah i'll
go from my raid night to my arena match
and figure out what i think is the best
for both of those and that's a process
we want to make really fluid so we're
building a save load feature that lets
you create your build name it save it
and then load it up very quickly and
freely talents were really about the
breadth of options we've made all these
different cool things over the years but
when are they at their coolest it's when
players can hold the building blocks of
what can make up their class their spec
and put them together in a way that
works for them so these are really cool
features that we've been working long
and hard on and we're very excited about
them and it's just an early preview of
the things we've been doing we can't
wait to see the reaction that you have
to them and please reach out to us and
let us know your thoughts on them and
next up we're going to talk about
professions in dragonflight
[Music]
hi i'm joanna and i'm eric and we're
going to talk about our plans for
professions in dragon flight professions
have been a staple of world of warcraft
forever and they've seen lots of really
cool incremental updates over their life
but for dragonflight we want to do
something a bit different we really want
to rethink professions and figure out
how to make them part of your identity
as a player if that's what you want we
really want to make sure that
professions feel fun and relevant across
all levels of game play that brings us
to our first update something that we're
calling crafting orders
if you want to have something crafted
for you but you don't have the skill or
the right profession to do it for
yourself you can have it crafted through
a crafting order
you can basically browse any of the
recipes that can be crafted pick the one
you want for yourself and then you
include some or all of the reagents
needed for the recipe including ones
that only you can get your hands on you
can find someone in person to do it
right in front of you for you or you can
also go to an npc and using an auction
house like interface send the order out
if you're doing this you can pick do you
want to send the order to anyone sort of
a public order or do you want to only
send it to your guild or to a specific
other player maybe it's a friend who you
know will be able to craft the item
really well for you if you are really
dedicated to your craft you're going to
be the best at what you do one of the
coolest things about this is the item
you had crafted can also be soul-bound
in the past you could only get your
hands on crafted soulbound items by
having that profession yourself now
anyone can have them crafted for them
which is really neat and really expands
the number of items that we can provide
that are really powerful because
everyone can have them crafted through
the crafting owner system this is also
really cool because it means as a
crafter you can start building your
client base people are going to come
back to you to get certain items maybe
you're the best at making it or you
always throw in a little something extra
you're also gonna be leveling up your
profession it's gonna be really great so
the first time you go to craft you're
gonna notice a lot of different things
but probably the biggest is the
introduction of quality both to your
crafted items and your gathered reagents
quality works in a pretty simple way if
you craft something that's a higher
quality it's just going to be better for
a piece of gear that probably means a
higher item level if it's for instance a
potion you know that might mean a more
powerful effect at a higher quality and
we're doing a lot of new things in the
ui we've put a lot of work into it to
make sure that the professions feel
really special and unique and another
thing you might notice in the crafting
ui that's new is the introduction of
stats specifically to your professions
both crafting and gathering and this is
another sort of major input into
quality probably the biggest source of
your ability to craft items at a higher
quality is through crafting
specializations we've had crafting
specializations in the past as far back
as original world of warcraft with
dragonflight
you can go out and earn
specialization points in a whole bunch
of different ways so maybe you find an
old book on a bookshelf in a ruin
somewhere or a hermit in a cave who can
teach you a little bit about your
profession so let's say you're a
blacksmith and you might decide that
first you want to become an armorsmith
and the more points you spend in
armorsmithing the better you're going to
get at crafting all armor this also
means that if you specialize one way
other people in your guild may
specialize in a completely different
path so this means that your guild could
have several top blacksmiths and
everybody's providing something unique
and valuable to the team which is really
cool now that reminds me of another
update we're actually adding crafting
tables to all the different crafting
professions we're going to take those
we're going to put them all in the main
city of valdrakin and you know you're
going to go in there and you're going to
get to see all the different players
crafting their items at their cool
crafting tables yeah it means you're
gonna walk into the city and you're
gonna see like all these alchemists
huddled over here and you're gonna see
all these blacksmiths over by the forge
there will be other players filling
orders or grabbing orders there's gonna
be a whole new crafting area that's
gonna make you feel really part of the
world it just seems like a much more
lively area than it has in the past what
i'm most excited about though is the
gear we're introducing new types of gear
for every profession and when you go to
say mine and node you're actually gonna
just switch into that gear it's gonna be
really great you're not gonna have to
carry that stuff around in your backpack
anymore it's actually gonna be dedicated
slots for each each of your pieces of
gear but i'm a numbers guy i love
progressing all pieces of profession
gear will have those special stats that
we mentioned before on them and as you
get your hands on better versions of the
gear you know it's really going to help
you get better at your profession i
can't wait thank you for tuning in to
the dragonfly deep dive you've heard a
lot about the content and changes coming
in dragonflight and we've got a lot more
in store for you in the coming months
until then we'll see you in azeroth
[Music]